all right let's go next to
where do we want to go next how about
um what about
sid from ohio sid you're on the air
um um yeah i was wondering what do you
think about the uh
the right the left alt media like young
turks and some other news
it seems like they spread a lot of
things like if not conspiracy false news
and i know that the right like fox and
you had some like breitbart
they do it on purpose what do you think
do you think the left also does it on
purpose
what fake news did the young turks
spread
well the young turk they constantly
promote like bernie sanders as the
it which we know he will if he would
have won that probably would not have
been great for left
you know like like they focus on like
ocasio-cortez they focus on
certain candidates and almost like run a
promotional um
you know promotional thing for them like
but how is that how is
how is that fake news well well they're
not they're not being fair to the
watchers to like
really give them like a good idea of who
these candidates are they focus on
certain policies like
like specifically like the one fake news
i do remember
is um one of the the popular girl
she during a debate was talking about um
hold on
like let's just back up just a little
bit okay okay who
the popular girl what are you saying
sorry i don't remember her name
but she's one of the main um you're
saying one of the hosts of the young
turks are you talking about anna yes
yes anna yeah yeah okay
actually went up for qualified
um like like people who have a college
degree but actually were working like
minimum wage jobs
so it actually fell and i when i checked
the facts on that that was wrong that
did not happen
now that was that politicon right that
was that politicon
okay so i don't know the statistic but
if anna
said it something that was wrong that's
not fake news that sounds like she was
mistaken
fake news would be like if i say hillary
clinton
gave birth to an alien baby like that
would be fake news
being wrong about an unemployment rate
isn't fake news and it also wasn't on
the young turks it sounds like it was in
the middle of a debate right right
right but it just seems like that the
vibe that i get from young turks like
they're
heavily heavily biased like you don't
seem like you're like like when i listen
to you you seem like somebody who's
reporting objective journalism listen i
i think i'm as biased as the young we're
all doing opinion shows
okay so i think that this is a media
literature we're all doing opinion shows
it's possible
that what you're saying is your opinions
differ from those on the young turks
where like the young turks was
too pro-bernie for you or too pro-aoc
for you
but um i i don't think it we're all
doing
opinion programs so i'm i would
recalibrate your critique maybe maybe
what you mean is
you don't agree politically with the
young turks is that maybe what you're
saying
um i feel like i feel like they don't
like like here's the thing like if you
watch fox like
they might like like i'm not i'm a
democrat myself but i feel like if you
watch fox like you might get a better
highlight of um of what the the
representative
like the downfalls of certain certain
representatives are like we can go down
the list of bernie
and aoc and how they support might
support some of the wrong things
but you're not going to hear that on on
the young terms like they will
they will only say good things about
them okay i don't know whether that's
true or not because
i don't i don't watch any of these shows
you know on my program
i at least try to give you like for
example when i talk about medicare for
all
i say medicare for all could be a great
way to organize healthcare here's all
the great things about it here's some
that are question marks and here's three
other ways we could organize healthcare
like i'm making that effort
the counter though would be do you think
you heard about the downsides of donald
trump on fox news
um there are a few
um demo it feels like democratic like
the guy who hosted the debate like he
would be
like hard on it the other guy who quit
fox he was also like going hard on him
but yeah they're very few who say right
yeah
so i think the the issue here is
the young turks and my show and sam
cedars show
we are opinion programs and we don't
hide that
the problem on fox is they present
opinion as if it's news and that's a
real problem so that's why i think
your example is a false equivalency
oh well i thought that when uh the fox
when they got sued
uh they they they said that their piece
is an opinion piece that's that's the
thing they had that that's not a
reliable news because
right that's that's a legal defense that
they use
but what fox is notorious for doing is
deliberately blurring the lines between
what is news and news and opinion
this is a big conversation about media
literacy i think it's really great that
you're thinking about these things
i think maybe if if you had maybe a
slightly more sophisticated
understanding of some of these media
literacy issues your
analysis would be even better i think is
the way i would put a positive spin on
it
okay all right all right my friend thank
you for the call i mean listen
it's great that people are even he he's
misinformed about the facts
and lacks some understanding but the
fact that he's thinking about this stuff
is more than can be said for a lot of
people
um that's uh that that's for sure all
right thanks everybody i really
appreciate everybody who called in today
we're out of time for today but we will
take more calls again in the future
and we're going to be right back with
more show right after this